President Trump is at the center of a
hurricane controversy this morning as he
stands by his inaccurate claim about the
state's threatened by durian at a
briefing yesterday the president
displayed a forecast map that raised
eyebrows it appeared to be altered with
a black line showing durian possibly
striking Alabama in one of the early
models here is the actual map from that
day put out by the National Hurricane
Center it does not show a threat to
Alabama been Tracy's at the White House
been what's this all about
well for the past couple of days the
president has been playing the role of
meteorologist in chief he's been
tweeting out updates about the hurricane
and his thoughts on where it might land
even sometimes at odds with his own
government forecasters now on Sunday mr.
Trump sent out this tweet saying that in
addition to Florida other states
including Alabama will mo most likely be
hit a few minutes later the National
Weather Service in Alabama tweeted
Alabama will not see any impacts from
Dorian but the president kept insisting
he was right he then displayed that map
in the Oval Office yesterday which looks
as if someone used a marker to include
Alabama in an effort to prove the
president was correct when asked about
it this is what the president said I
know that was in the original forecast
they thought it would get it as a piece
of it that map the use of this today
look like it almost had like a sharpie
now the government's National Hurricane
Center which issues that map never said
Alabama was threatened
oddly enough knowingly misrepresenting a
government weather forecast is a crime
and it's punishable by up to 90 days in
prison as for now the president keeps
insisting he was right all along
Dayna all right then interesting no
thank you very much